en allant récupérer son fils à la crèche
une mère de famille a récemment fait une
terrible découverte ce sont des traces
de morsure qui sont constatées sur le
visage le cou et les selles du petit
garçon prévenu par l'établissement que
leur fils de 2 ans avait subi une petite
griffure les parents de Liam était loin
de s'imaginer qu'ils allaient en réalité
le retrouver des figurés il avait le
visage tout gonflé marqué j'étais sous
le choc une affaire terrible qui en
rappelle une autre celle de cette mère
de famille qui avait elle aussi retrouvé
son fils blessé à la crèche moi et le
seul mot qui répète à longueur de
journée c'est bobo
côté tandis qu'ils ont annoncé avoir
porté plainte les parents du petit Liam
sont toujours dans l'incompréhension et
toutes les hypothèses sont envisagées y
compris celles de la maltraitance de la
part des employés traumatismes crânien
coup morsure le cri du cœur de Sonia et
Sébastien après avoir récupéré leur fils
de 2 ans des figurés à la crèche
[Musique]
merci d'être là je sais que c'est
difficile pour vous d'en parler et on
comprend tout à fait parce que vous avez
vu à la réaction du public vous avez vu
la réaction des des chroniqueurs vous
êtes donc les parents d'un petit Liam
qui a deux ans travailler tous les deux
donc forcément votre enfant reste à la
crèche c'est le cas de beaucoup de
familles on est bien obligé on est en
sécurité quand nos enfants sont à la
crèche vous allez le récupérer lorsque
vous terminez votre journée mais lundi
dernier ça c'est pas passé comme
d'habitude
Sonia lorsque vous arrivez on vous a
annoncé qu'il était arrivé un petit
incident à votre fils
qu'est-ce que c'est qui vous accueilli
c'est la directrice la directrice de la
crèche donc vous a dit quoi vous
attendez vas-y est-ce que je peux vous
voir de petites secondes
elle m'a dit il y a eu un incident avec
Liam
il s'est fait griffer d'accord il s'est
fait griffer
quelle a été parce que en fait les
versions d'hiver la version de la
directrice c'est laquelle il s'est fait
griffer par un enfant par un enfant un
autre enfant de la crèche d'accord
et le personnel de la crèche vous leur
avez parlé oui et aussi fait mordre
d'accord
c'était ils ont ils ont désigné le même
enfant ou pas du tout
donc là vous l'aviez vu votre fils avant
qu'elle vous en parle ou pas donc là
pour l'instant vous le voyez
parce qu'il m'avait même pas appelé en
fait dans la matinée
je suis arrivée c'est là qu'on m'a
annoncé la griffure alors bon je
comprends ça arrive
ça arrive c'est des enfants c'est normal
une griffure un petit coup
je comprends et après on va parler d'une
morsure donc là je me suis dit c'est
quand même bizarre et là vous dites vous
avez demandé à voir votre fils forcément
oui il dormait mon fils dans le dortoir
tout seul sans surveillance d'accord
donc là
déjà on fait pas dormir à nous dormir
quoi voilà déjà là vous le voyez
là
on voit les photos
voilà c'est
incroyable
le pire ils ont jamais contacté pour
nous dire il y a eu un incident jamais
appeler donc là vous trouvez votre
enfant dans cet état forcément là vous
vous faites quoi je le porte et en fait
quand j'ai porté mon fils lui-même il a
eu aucune réaction ça veut dire qu'il va
regarder il était
il a pas pleuré il a pas parlé rien donc
je l'ai porté je suis sortie et en fait
on m'a parlé mais j'étais dans j'étais
tellement en état de choc en fait
j'entends rien j'ai juste dit donnez-moi
ces affaires et je m'en vais et je suis
parti en fait parce que vous avez même
pas discuter et vous avez excusé plein
de fois je suis désolé ça se reproduira
plus je suis désolé je suis désolé oui
mais
j'ai préféré partir en fait à ce moment
là vous vous ressentez vous ressentez
quoi vous appelez votre mari vous quand
je suis sorti j'ai appelé
à Sébastien Sébastien vous imaginez tout
de suite le les dégâts qui est sur votre
fils ou pas du tout moi en fait quand
elle m'appelle ouais je suis au travail
à m'appelle à me dire
dès qu'elle m'appelle déjà je sens qu'il
y a quelque chose à savoir elle me dit
un problème avec Liam et tout il a eu un
incident à la crèche d'accord
il est défiguré et elle a
Judit tu es où elle me dit bah devant la
crèche tu bouges pas j'arrive normal
j'ai pris ma voiture je suis parti je
les rejoins à la crèche
quand je vois ouvert la porte de la
voiture je me suis dit c'est pas
possible
c'est trop c'est
je l'ai pris j'étais bon à la directrice
je dis qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
on peut pas
l'enfant qu'il l'a mordu là c'est pas
possible non mais en plus là
les blessures il y a dû avoir des cris
et durant des pleurs à un moment c'est
on vous invite alerté ça veut dire que
ça a duré pendant longtemps ça a duré
plus que longtemps même il a un trou
dans la nuque un trou sous les aisselles
faut arrêter faut arrêter regardez c'est
quoi ça on sait même pas ce que c'est ça
se trouve on s'est posé toutes les
questions ça se trouve à la portée ou ça
se trouve une je sais pas franchement on
sait pas on est dans le doute
il parle pas de griffure il parle pas de
morsure
un érythème un hématome de 20 cm voilà
bon on les a vu donc là vous allez voir
la directrice elle vous dit quoi
asseyez-vous monsieur cousin ça se
reproduira plus
de
ça se reproduira plus en fait on a
entendu pleurer
ils sont partis dans le dortoir et ils
l'ont retrouvé comme ça voilà et je lui
dis mais qu'il surveillait personne moi
je vais vous dire ces personnes là
seront sanctionnées à nous a dit
certains de ce qui s'est passé et qui
sont entendus pleurer au début ils sont
dit bon bah ça pleure ça va se calmer ça
a dû continuer continuer continuer et je
pense qu'ils ont laissé faire pendant un
peu de temps et ce qui a fait que les
les sœurs sont celles que vous avez là
et bien sûr que vous avez découvert je
pense aux Gilles alors ça pourrait
peut-être même être plus grave parce que
l'enquête est ouverte pour violence sur
mineur de moins de 15 ans et violence
aggravée donc dans violence aggravées
les enquêteurs qui travaillent beaucoup
du commissariat d'Aubervilliers
notamment se demande si ça ne pourrait
pas tout simplement être de la
maltraitance comme ils éventuellement
par un adulte et je voulais vous poser
une question parce que selon mes infos
vous auriez recueilli des témoignages
d'autres parents
antérieurs est-ce que ça c'est vrai ou
pas oui
après je vais pas tout dire non plus
parce qu'il y a une enquête oui il y a
deux personnes
qui travaillaient à la crèche
ils sont partis
et ils vont être entendre ils vont ils
vont s'expliquer surtout
alors on m'a dit que mon fils dormait
par terre
plein de choses mais je vais pas je vais
laisser faire l'enquête Sonia et
Sébastien un moment
ce que vous voulez pas demander qui a
fait ça ah si
vous dit désigne un des enfants vous
pouvez aller voir les parents voir si
c'est vraiment lui pour voir si c'est
voilà ce qui s'est passé pour essayer
que les parents l'interrogent
ils nous ont pas dit on a demandé on lui
a dit mais qui lui a fait ça nous en dit
on peut pas vous donner le nom de
l'enfant après
c'est du bien entre guillemets c'est
peut-être facile de remettre la faute
sur un enfant ils ont deux ans un an et
demi deux ans et demi non mais après les
enfants
et votre fils il vous a dit vous avez
essayé de l'interroger on a essayé de
parler avec lui de lui dire est-ce que
ta copine elle a fait bobo à Didou
est-ce que ton copain non est-ce que ce
Didou il est tombé dans les escaliers
parce que tout le temps lui dit
attention les escaliers attention
il parle souvent de ces bobos regarde
tout le temps tout le temps bobo bobo
ma cousine bisous ma chérie
bon la bouche il a du chocolat il vient
de déjeuner
et donc là aujourd'hui donc vous êtes
dans le flou total dans le flou total
vous n'avez aucune aucune réponse
aujourd'hui vous le gardez à la maison
forcément quand vous faites
je partage
on se reliant
vous dites que depuis ce qui s'est passé
où le trouver changer vous le trouvez
voilà il est traumatisé qu'est-ce qui se
passe
toutes les nuits il se réveille en
pleurant et d'ailleurs on a rendez-vous
avec un psychologue il va le chercher à
partir de lundi
et après moi je voudrais aussi un
un vraiment un gros point vraiment je
veux bien qu'il ait été griffé mais je
veux bien qu'il ait été mordu
mais je sais pas si une griffure ou une
morsure
ça peut déclencher un traumatiscrâne
c'est ça parce que après un passage aux
urgences il s'est avéré que votre fils
avait un traumatisme crânien
assez violent ça aurait pu être même
plus grave
le pire c'est que dans l'état qu'il est
il refond dormir sans surveillance
encore une fois
sans surveillance en fait ils ont frotté
deux fois selon il aurait pu il aurait
pu vomir il aurait pu mourir carrément
carrément bien sûr
vous allez porter plainte
au commissariat au commissariat j'ai
pris ma plainte ils sont vraiment je
vais les laisser faire l'enquête comme
je viens mais ils sont vraiment douteux
ils m'ont dit que l'enquête a fera ils
vont aller jusqu'au
doutes ils ont été choqués forcément
comme très choqués et voilà qui retient
l'habitude et Gilles ils ont ils ont
balayé les premières thèses qui vous
avez été données aussi qui serait tombé
de choses
alors c'est un meuble qui aurait pu être
tombé
par un enfant et pour le moment battu en
brèche parce que on parle quand même
dans le rapport de blessure à mains nues
oui blessure à mains nues ça peut je
prends toutes les précautions d'usage ça
peut signifier des coûts et pas des
coups d'un enfant donc effectivement ils
sont très douteux des premières
explications qui ont été fournies et une
enquête internale à la crèche il y a une
enquête qui a été ouverte et
voilà la thèse qui pourrait être celle
d'une de la maltraitance commise encore
une fois au conditionnel commise par un
adulte et une thèse qui est
pour le moment largement retenu par les
enquêteurs voilà ça pourrait être c'est
déjà très grave vu ce qu'on voit ça
pourrait être et là c'est encore plus
grave encore plus grave ce que quand on
regarde la morsure entre guillemets
l'enfant il a une dent
il a qu'une dent à ronde et c'est quoi
c'est un clou qui l'a
moi je me mange j'ai des traces dedans
regardez il y a pas de traces dedans moi
je pense pas un pincement quand on pince
regardez l'effet que ça fait
non
c'est pas un jeu
juste moi ce que j'aimerais savoir si
c'est quels sont les versions que vous a
donné vous a dit quoi parce que c'est
incroyable en fait on oublie je dis mais
c'est qui qui a fait ça c'est la
première question que je pose je lui ai
demandé à la directrice quand j'étais la
voir je lui ai dit qui a fait ça elle
m'a dit c'est un enfant vous inquiétez
pas il y aura des sanctions de prise ils
étaient tout seul dans le dortoir
comment ça se fait déjà qu'ils sont tout
seul dans le dortoir c'est interdit même
s'il y a un enfant il y a il y a une
surveillance
et de là m'a dit oui c'est un enfant
c'est un enfant il a pas voulu nous dire
le nom et tout ça et là apparemment
parce qu'il y a eu un reportage sur
France 3 hier
entre guillemets
tous tous les
les puéricultrices tous ceux qui
s'occupent de Liam ils étaient présents
ils ont vu ils ont ils sont tous
intervenus en même temps ils ont vu
l'enfant sur lui il maintiennent leur
version de la morsure et la griffure
j'insiste beaucoup sur ce point là c'est
que mon fils il a été voir un médecin
légiste la police judiciaire
là j'ai pas les résultats parce que ça
va être confié au procureur et au et aux
enquêteurs
mais
où ils sont ces traces de griffes il a
que des hématomes où sont les griffures
tout simplement
et ils arrêtent de
cet enfant un moment il
aurait aimé savoir
envie de savoir qui qu'est-ce qui
quelqu'un fait ça et là il vous dites la
raison qui vous invoque c'est quoi c'est
la loi c'est la loi c'est comme ça ils
veulent pas nous dire
et le traumatisme cannien c'est un
enfant je pense pas moi ça paraît pas du
tout des blessures d'enfants
c'est vrai que peut-être qu'il est
peut-être tombé après peut-être qu'il
s'est cognait alors comme j'ai jamais
observé d'autres problèmes dans cette
crèche avant cet incident énorme non
mais c'est pour ça oui il faut pas
apprécier il y a eu peut-être voilà un
manquement de surveillance ou c'est sûr
que ce soit un enfant si moi je je vous
dis non mais toutes les hypothèses c'est
possible oui c'est un peut-être un enjeu
peut-être qu'il a poussé je sais pas je
crois qu'ils ont 2 ans et demi hein à
2h30 ouais le plus grand et il y a
plusieurs endroits de ce côté-ci
qui est touché hein
qu'il a un trou il a une plaie dans la
nuque il a on va voir ce que vont dire
les les enquêteurs vous avez raison de
prendre toutes les précautions
moi c'est ce que j'ai dit ça peut
arriver un accident ça arrive un meuble
il aurait pu tomber il aurait pu
trébucher dans les escaliers après être
monté en haut des escaliers mais
dites-nous la vérité on veut savoir la
vérité on veut savoir ce qui s'est passé
on veut savoir
ils vont cuisiner tout le monde y
compris
différents endroits ça a duré un certain
temps
c'est tout ils sont même dans la merde
ah oui oui non c'est sûr
moi le plus important aussi c'est que le
petit aille mieux et que ils se sentent
mieux et qu'il arrive à reprendre
confiance on a rendez-vous mardi avec un
psychologue et il fait des cauchemars
tout le temps bobo bobo bobo
on veut juste qu'il aille mieux et
qu'après on est la lumière sur sur cette
affaire ça va être quoi la suite là pour
l'instant vous le garder à la maison ou
pas on attend
la normalement doit avoir une
réponse de la directrice pour nous
retrouver une place en crèche on attend
on est dans l'attente et on sera là vous
nous tenez au courant et merci en tout
cas d'avoir été avec nous et on fait un
gros bisou vraiment lui faire un gros
bisou s'il est trop mignon et c'est vrai
que voilà on est tous perchés par ce
qu'on a vu forcément